yeah which which brings me to the next
bit which you will all love this is is
this the right story oh here we go
Brian bartels 20 year old accused of
inciting violence and riots in
Pittsburgh in police custody I think
it's not just that I think he actually
tried burning a building down oh wow
he's in big trouble so but here's the
best part you got to read the yeah you
got yeah we got to hear this 20 year old
Brian Bartles the man accused of
inciting violence and rides in
Pittsburgh on Saturdays in police
custody
Bartles turned himself in oh really
at police headquarters Monday he arrived
with an adult male and adult female hmm
who could that have been yeah we have a
video let's uh let's play the video
that's the walk of shame right there
it's a red block oof
mr. Bartel do you have anything to say
about what happened on Saturday anything
anything you want to write for that
police car
you have anything to say all right now
I gotta say men first of all that dude
really does look like his dad like it
looks like him you know I mean well they
totally do their demise okay yeah that's
that's his dad you know what I want to
say to those parents you're bad parents
yeah they brought him in at least yeah
that's a good nation but how do you let
your kid become that messed up 20 years
old not destroying a police car
apparently look at this look at this
Bartles is facing charges of
institutional vandalism riding in
reckless endangerment according to
police he's responsible for breaking the
windows out of a Pittsburgh police car
against the wishes of peaceful
protesters was scumbag yeah man
after he was arrested police say they
received a call from Bartles attorney
earlier in the day saying Bartle would
turn himself in Monday afternoon Bartles
had no comment as he walked into police
headquarters
his attorney also told KDKA is Nicole
Ford he has no comment there was so much
destruction downtown after Saturday's
violent demonstration and police believe
Bartles from the Allison Park area
helped incite the violence Pittsburgh
provided a photo of him wearing all
black with a black bandana around his
face I don't know that it looks like his
hair is kind of frosted there I don't
see you in another frame and the other
person looks like him okay no that's a
little I think something happened where
they knew it was him
okay and then start showing photos of
him you know all right
well through they say they say oh it
shows out Schaller police in Pittsburgh
served a search warrant at a home in
Shaler Sunday so that so they're coming
for you men Bartles was not there but
investigators say they found evidence
that links him to the protest guns spray
guns
whoa spray paint and gloves also found
during the search warrant X for
execution was the sweatshirt matching
the one seen in the video of the
protests on Saturday oh they got you
yep you see that you see the Nashville
perp walk No
the cops actually went to found the guy
at his house brought him out he's 24 and
they stood him up and took a nice little
picture and tweeted it out I want
everyone to know what you look like man
could you imagine you know why I'm
saying these parents are bad parents
could you this kid's life is over
yeah he's probably gonna well we'll see
what the government does to him and I
wouldn't be surprised if they cut him to
kind of deal but it's it's very likely I
mean these are felony charges
I'd imagine right like burning a police
car that's gotta be that seems felonious
yeah not sure I mean I kind of open it
no that's a misdemeanor you get a slap
on the rest of fine for torching a
police car no I imagine this dude is is
it's dawn for man but so many of these
people don't realize yeah they're on
camera yep there's a Mercer everywhere
there's a video everywhere what these
people understand these and that
criminals don't either is the power of
optics yep
you ever watch a police chase the
helicopter is like how far away these
helicopters like a mile two miles away
and they zoom right and they can read
the license plate mm as they follow you
and the guys in the helicopter
mm-hmm so there's a video of this woman
and she's walking on the street and
she's got like a hockey stick or
something and she's not wearing a mask
and she walks right up and you can see
her face clear as day because I guess
she didn't realize the camera was really
really far away then she pulls the mask
off but I trying to smash a window it's
like well you're gonna you're going to
jail to it yeah these people man why
sacrifice your life over all of this you
know especially when most of them are
there talking about it and it's not even
about George anymore it's like what what
are you doing you're just you're just
making you're taking the point and
changing it you know you're you're
you're you're not honoring his death
that's for sure it's not about it it's
not about him at all anymore and that's
that's the worst this is a weird thing
about about these people it's like you
know you know what I think it is the
media rag on in sells mm-hmm
they're they're like it's young men sing
at home and you know in their mothers
basements yeah what do you think these
people are the dudes clearly out of
shape and he's got stupid weapons and
it's
parents brought in the police department
the problem is the media never called
out the same problem on the left of
these people with no function no purpose
no skills and then they have to go to
jail because they do really really dumb
things but here's our thing about it
it's like I was saying about the the
blunt-force terror versus the extreme
when it comes to like the in cell stuff
there's a couple people a small handful
several people out of the past decade or
so when you look at what the hold on
extreme acts and they get a ton of
attention okay when you look at the left
there's thousands of these people doing
a low-level terror and they never get
any press but now when there's thousands
of them doing that all at the same time
and and they're they're being separated
from the peaceful protesters that are
trying to go out and protest you know a
death of you know one of their kin it's
like it's clears day you know it's
there's a split line now which is good
we needed that and especially when I
mean they tackle that they tackled an NT
foot person and that's what we need to
see more but it's it's it's still blurry
okay I was talking to a friend about
this who was telling me that you know
their friends and family want to go out
and support black lives matter mm-hmm
and I was like you know you know it's
it's a tough call yeah you got your
First Amendment right to do it but you
realize they're exploiting you right
these activists want you to go out and
form a crowd so they can exploit your
your anger and turn it into something
else let me tell you these person are
professionals when Trayvon Martin
protests pipe sparked up right mm-hmm
one of the most disgusting things I've
ever seen
true awesome protesters organized a
black lives matter rally okay and
they're marching and one of the it's
actually really funny sad for the
organizers they got to a point when I
started yelling where should we go as
they marched and the organizers were
like the courthouse we want to bring to
the police and they went yeah and then
Occupy Wall Street anti-football
ran to the front of the protest and it
started going like this
waving backwards with their hands and
then turned the other direction to bring
him to Wall Street and the organizers
who actually organize the whole protest
would won't want to go to the courthouse
we're going no no no no no no whoa whoa
stop stop too late huh they don't get it
man and so what happened was the Occupy
people brought them to Wall Street into
the bowl where they danced and just
jumped around and you know these people
are really good at shutting down
protests it's so easy yeah you want to
know another secret if there's a big
March happening in say like New York but
and let's say it's only semi organized
where like they said meet up here then
we're gonna march all you have to do is
get like two or three friends and if
you're ten feet in front of the crowd
any direction you turn the entire crowd
goes with you that's why they have the
organizers walking backwards cause it's
their hands yeah and the organizers
choose where they go you can even easily
easily override because they'll have two
or three people and I've seen it happen
well I've seen journalists accidentally
guide protests into ridiculous areas
just because they're trying to get a
picture so the journalist is wrong in
front yeah and they're taking pictures
and they say and they turn around start
walking and then I was like one moment
during occupy walk a guy pulls out his
phone and he's walking forward in the
truck turning left and then all the
protesters start turning left with him
and then the organize started freaking
out like you know you're getting off of
Broadway what are you doing and too late
thank you they follow the journalist and
the whole March just turns a notice any
idea what's going on mom cuz no one's
paying attention you know that's kind of
what it is with these kids that are
going out and riding and now what man
it's it's I don't think anybody really
what I mean by anybody's I don't think
the people in big cities are paying
attention at all to why it's happening
and what's going on and who's doing it
no there's probably those you say
organizers they're the ones who are
aware and those people exist and they
have probably have groups of people
around them that are with it but then
for the most part the message gets lost
in in the violence and the the wildness
of what names maybe that's intentional I
ain't I think it is there's people out
there that are definitely trying to take
the message away you know what I was
thinking what I'm a part of me thinks
it's possible that ante foe has actually
long since been infiltrated by overt
white supremacists because you think
about their tactics an tyfa is the most
effective
propaganda if auntie pho is actual white
supremacists it is the most effective
white supremacist campaign ever ever
undertaken think about it
all of these riots where they're all
blaming black lives matter for it you
know and now people trying to say aunty
fine auntie father trying to point to
the white people try to post videos
about it yeah think about this if
there's a video of a black man pointing
out two young white people who are
talking about burning down buildings and
he's like no no not in my neighborhood
yeah who are these people who come - who
are these white people who come to black
neighborhoods to burn and destroy their
property in their wealth doesn't sound
like an anti-racist does it it sounds
like something out of the Klan it sounds
like what the Democrats used to do a
hundred years ago
yeah I could see that it's funny I
remember because they were trying to
claim that Trump made a George Wallace
quote okay when he said the looting
starts oh it starts on it's actually not
it's like a chief he'd Lee or whatever
from Miami yeah but the funny thing is
wasn't Wallace a Democrat he was these
people don't get it is that they really
don't get it didn't learn yesterday but
they've learned a valuable lesson if you
say you're anti anti feh that means you
can't be a fascist oh yeah it means
anybody who opposes you must be right
and they determined that because they're
Democrats they can't be racist because
they say they're not so I'll ask you man
when have we seen the the alt-right and
far-right whatever go into black
neighborhoods and successfully destroy
all of their property no no but have we
seen aunt Eva do it yeah yes we have so
I got a wonder man you know and of
course you do see looters downtown yeah
and one of the things that that bugs me
out is a lot of people are posting
videos of black people looting buildings
and stuff okay and I'm like come on in
there's videos of white people looting
to you know different neighborhoods one
of the annoying things for me is that
you can go to specific neighborhoods
because of segregation like and I mean
social segregation like what people
choose to live each other right and
easily film specific things and trying
to tribute it to one one group or
another so I don't think it's fair to do
that I do think it's fair to point out
we got a ton of videos like that woman
with a brick walking up to the car full
of white people being like what are you
doing why would you hand this out
they're white supremacists man mmm-hmm
and so the joke is they're white
supremacist with guilty consciences
they're just white supremacist men yeah
you might be right
so I can say this it is a fact that in
the Pacific Northwest anti food does
collude with white supremacist groups
this is this is this is a fact so there
hasn't been any strong reporting on it
other than people I know who like I'm
talking alleged journalists ok who do
sourcing with various extremist groups
know for a fact they coordinate with
each other for specific reasons they
both think each other is a useful idiot
and both provide Intel for them against
the government so an tyfa is absolutely
willing to be like what have you guys
heard what can you tell us yeah and the
white supremacists are like here's what
we know here you can watch out for
because the white supremacists don't
like the government either not all of
them yeah but a lot of them are like
insurrectionist anti-establishment and
what do you expect I think there would
be great if there was stronger reporting
on this but no one wants to burn their
sources because the moment someone says
this person did it yeah then they lose
all their connections to an tyfa like
they have the one person to feeding of
all this info so they're like you know
oh i can't tell you what do you think
about that that picture it's going
around of auntie for being infiltrated
and taken over just to find out who's in
it oh the OC auntie bo1 yeah i think
it's fake you think it's fake i mean
it's it's it's probably real to an
extent yeah yeah and it's you know so so
i better way to put it i think it's i
think it's real okay but i don't think
it's like a powerful large auntie for
organization i think it was probably
just an account that was tweeting these
things and then maybe made some
connections and got some you know
private information okay but I'm not
convinced that it's like you're gonna
see a database drop of all of these
auntie for people from you know Orange
County or whatever but I actually do
think that's an Tifa for the most part
wants to overthrow the US government
they said about fascism they've said it
right there's videos of them talking
about it oh absolutely
right absolutely they want their you
know communist utopia or whatever Trump
and a bunch of people are saying they're
anarchists man they're not anarchists
that annoys that annoys me
anarchists you've got right-wing
anarchists who are you know
trying to sell land or something yeah
and then you've got left-wing anarchists
who are trying to share the water moans
they grew on the land and that's that's
that's that's anarchy there's no
Authority it's people just chilling
using violence on someone is asserting
authority over them so the right-wing
and our kists and libertarian types have
the non-aggression principle and you
can't aggress against someone else where
they draw that line it gets difficult
the left doesn't really have that but
it's because it's it's almost impossible
to be a left libertarian it's almost
impossible to like find a group that
agrees and everything it just cooperates
no it's not in human nature well that
won't ever happen because there's
billions and billions of us and we all
have different upbringings different
personalities different everything on a
small scale at codit sure on a small
scale like we are not living in small
scales anymore right or there's billions
of us well that's that that's also why I
think laissez-faire capitalism doesn't
work either yeah because then you end up
with the corporation yeah exactly it's
like you know you can not have anything
cuz they own everything yeah so there's
got to be some kind of limited
regulation but all of these people seem
to think they know what's best but the
craziest thing is if I was actually to
make a bet like if someone said to me
Tim what do you think is the most likely
reason for all of this I would say
stupid college kids who are easily
manipulated because they have no purpose
are being manipulated by online
influences from various countries you
know in order to be like part of
something deranged no no like and orange
they're driving to the derangement but
that's part of it so they argue that
Russia is trying to do this and like
it's true but the scale to which they
argue it is probably not true it's like
some Russian influences trying to incite
and stoke the fire but I can tell you
man al-jazeera plus they were well
funded San Francisco digital media
outlet putting out nothing but police
brutality videos getting two billion
views per per year well and what do you
think that does the mind of young people
as they're as they're growing up their
brands no that's the truth all cops are
bad yeah all cops are bad and all cops
are racist and all this other crazy
nonsense right so now they're outside
like watching watching the protesters
outside of the White House was like
they're all chanting black lives matter
you know I
you know why that's nightmarish why they
were all white I'm like you know man
there's the weirdest thing all these
white people coming out being angry for
someone they don't know
would you like to an extent I can
respect yeah yeah but it's a cult man
they have this weird Dogma and then
what's crazy is when you actually see
black people be like yo stop they're
like shut up so I think they're white
supremacists do something yeah dude I'm
convinced seeing all this stuff that
people are gonna become extremely racist
they're gonna go buy all the guns they
can and it is it is it is a white
supremacists dream come true when you
know you know about what happened with
Sarah Jong no she was an agent when we
got hired by the New York Times
okay and she meet like she merely got
called out for years years worth of anti
white tweets like very really brutal
just brutal stuff I remember do you
remember any of the tweets she said I'm
just talking about how she was hoping
that something like all how much she
disliked old white men that was her main
focus she wouldn't get rid of all the
old white men and I was like that's not
a really good look for someone who's
going on to an editorial board but she
was judge she was saying like all white
people this white people that and just
really it was really messed up stuff I'm
not gonna plug tweets on that and the
New York Times defended her and you know
what the response was from actual white
supremacists hmm I wish we had a
thousand more of her yeah so all of a
sudden these leftists these Antipa media
type start writing white supremacists
are furious over what she's saying and I
saw that and I'm like no they aren't
they love it they love it why why are
these people in the media lying to
protect the white supremacist that is
weird
because they are white supremacist so
the reason the reason these white
supremacists liked what Sarah John was
saying okay was that it was essentially
black propaganda for white people and
they were hoping when white people saw
how much she hated them and was in an
institution of power it would make them
hate reject it make them hate the media
reject the media and it would make them
quote racially conscious when you start
seeing people and high levels of power
say that because of your race you're bad
and you should die that's what they want
to happen yeah because then it makes
white people react based on their race
one of the ways they like that
explained it memes as they get attacked
over and over again because white people
are privileged so then they form an
identity group for white people and then
get attacked for being racist and
they're like it's what you told us we
weren't and like it's the only way to
defend ourselves so what you started
seeing from the rise of this like it's
called leftist identitarian ism groups
like black lives matter for instance was
the inverse the alright and then you see
people like at the New York Times
getting away with it just cheering it on
and then it leads to what we see in the
white house thousands of white people
chanting black lives matter and so you
know I'm talking to my friends about it
and I'm like man look I get it racism
all that stuff big problem but the
things you're saying make no sense like
if I was talk to you about wealth
inheritance okay and the destruction of
property and how that translates your
response to me is that I'm focused on
the rioters instead of a man losing his
life when I try to explain to you that
you know the reason why I came over the
rapper's name dream or whatever it was
saying don't destroy my town he was
saying it because he wants to give his
kids an inheritance so that they have
institutional power but when these white
people like Angela show up to black
neighborhoods and burn everything down
then all of the white liberals cheer for
it that means the next generation will
never recover
that means you literally have white
antifoam making sure the black people
can't come up and then the Democrats
offer them policies that's destructive
things that you know make it so that's
they're either not going to work or that
their homes are destroyed or they're
gonna stay in that class forever exactly
no they can't they can't move up that's
why that's my that's my my loose
conspiracy of an tyfa is secretly white
supremacist hmm yeah or they're not I
mean you can I think it's fair to call
him that what some people have called
them is white supremacists with guilty
consciences thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you